it's been a while since we had one of
these talks it wasn't that long ago we
were fighting just to stay alive but
it's not like that we build it we're
growing still ready to deal with this
world on its own turn
we're all gonna pitch in and make sure
that sanctuary has what it needs so
y'all can get back on your feet
bless you a glass
no matter what happens
it's human nature to come together
that's a real pretty picture you paint
their ring when do I get to see don't
you ever get tired of acting like you're
still with your horns do you know when
were five minutes eight years you told
me that soon you'd be the one to follow
in me but you didn't because I wasn't
someone to follow the changes now you
think you got all this on lock we need
to start talking about making some rules
an agreement between all the communities
like this is how we treat each other and
this is what happens when we don't
Darrell stop
that small group we had back in the
beginning
he could do anything that was right
just don't feel right
John Ross
figure out how to make it work you don't
know if we're gonna forgive each other
Rick
if they can even move on
I just wanted to pull that trigger
and before it begins
[Applause]
when it finally goes to [ __ ]
and there we'll make sure you come back
and you tell me all about that date
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before it's done you go
it's about all of us together keep doing
that they'll see we're all on the same
side
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't same salary will you tell me
who were you before before all this I
was a music teacher where two tables at
a truck stop
she says she was a journalist but she's
just being modest and who are you now
you
[Applause]